we have another fan favorite question
will the states be higher than any other
and see very far
willis takes me higher vendors for
absolutely any other forms without God
at Daniel Steven Marquez what will be
the runtime of vendors for the running
time for the ventures for currently
sitting right so we'll see if that holds
all right Danny fan DXM wants to know
how far long is Avengers 4 in the
editing process we are we're about
halfway through the editing process so
we're really just scratching the surface
on all of our VFX shots there are more
than 3,000 VFX shots the movie does
require a lot of time and thought and
energy and effort I think we're very
early in that phase of getting the
effects done we just started working
down semester in score
we're still editing pictures
so I got Lima what was the best part of
filming the Winter Soldier
that's part of filming what was
everything you know my brother and I are
very fond that
worked very hard at home and for us was
our introduction to the Marvel Universe
and important to us by the way from a
storytelling standpoint sort and it's
starting to interface with the fans but
in a way that you know we're we took
ownership over those characters and then
took the story that started in when our
soldier in period all the way through
adventure sports I think you'll see that
you know there's a there's a narrative
rather between all the movies that we've
done from Barbara's very important us
very important American elite or the
writers who will work with us on all
four movies if there is a continuity in
a bill to the narrative and in winter so
it really was in section of all of it
was a tonal shift for the market
universe is where we really started
rocking the boat and that's something
else is important too
you know the most aggressive narrative
is when you you can you know surprise
people and give them something that
they're not expecting and and shift
their perspective this common area that
is recently before we take a look here
at the new order before we do any more
questions where's that little fellow
scientist moved to the drink that was
finished just to give a nice room Oh
oh my god how they realizing this is my
second favorite thing
like that sir amazing
so now I've got two drinks in front of
me inside of the temporary okay so let's
what else oh yeah we got arial 'arial
mia 14 she wants to know will you'd be
working with Marvel again we would
absolutely love to work with Marvel yeah
yes the Troy Alonzo like family to us
it's a reason that we
that you know we prioritize working
environment and quality of life and
relationships questioning prioritize
it's been an amazing experience what
they've done over the last decade is
just unprecedented and they've done it
because they are such a close family and
it's been an amazing experience for us
so we've gladly
so at Chucky de feu when can we expect
the trailer big question when can we
expect the trailer or may not see it the
calendar
so last but not least everyone's waiting
we want to know what is the Avengers for
title the only one person asked that
question actually only one probably one
person
the next one is called Avengers
so we were just gonna live again so we
can rectify that
so the actually the official title for
Avengers 4 is
[Music]
[Music]